how do you still believe in god after
everything you've seen and you've been
through how do you still have that faith
you know
his faith is
i always believed in god when i went to
prison
i
joined an indian group
indian native american
native american i joined the group
because they shut down smoking and
uh
2004 i believe it was and i wanted to
smoke and there was no smoking no more
in the prisons and federal prisons you
were done it was over
so i saw them smoking in a circle
passing the pizza pipe around
wow i went to them and i said listen
i'd like to join because they had
probably religious exclusions or
something yeah
so
they said you got to go to the chaplain
in feds they could change your religion
so i said okay i went to the chopped
plants i want to become a native
american
they did it
they changed my religion and i went and
i in that circle they accepted me
and i smoked and i stole some of that
tobacco to bring it back into my cell
so when i at night i put on the tv nice
cup of coffee i light up a cigarette
after the god makes his rounds and i
smoke my [ __ ] brains out
but i got to respect their religion
what is their religion their religion is
they believe in grandfather grandfather
is a road to god they believe in god
like anybody else
higher power yeah everybody believes in
god the muslims believe in god allah
they go to god
the christians believe in it jews
believe in it everybody believes that
everybody has a separate road to god
i'm no different i'm just not on some of
your roads you tell me well if you
didn't find jesus you ain't going to
heaven yeah
well maybe i won't
maybe i won't i don't know
but i believe in god just like everybody
else so this grandfather they talk about
this religion yeah
grandfather you know that's that's their
religion so i did it for five years with
that i even went into wicca
some guys friends of mine said sammy
you're not an indian no
that's the choice that's the witches
well it's which is it's not which is
like you see on television which is is
is in their religion a witch is nothing
more than a term like a priest
a rabbi or but he's a witch
he can't perform anything as a witch he
can't do anything
about black magics all that that's
television [ __ ]
but the wicked
they do have some weird but thing but
there's still a religion that wants to
go wherever all religions got some weird
[ __ ]
you know but that's that's an
organization
and their road and their money
but god is god everybody believes in god
some to different degrees and weird
degrees and whatever but of course i
believe in god
you know i do i learned how to do
artwork in prison
sometimes in arizona where um
pretty legit work though like this is
not like artwork like artwork like real
work
yeah i've seen some of the work he's
done it's it's very impressive like
painting like thinking oh no no
seriously like i don't know i do chuck
hall
do you have any afterwards can you show
them some of the pictures yeah i got
them on my phone my girl can show it
yeah but
in arizona i get up and i look at the
sunset or the sun brides or something
and i look at it
and it's it's so
[ __ ] beautiful
and i say
who can do that
god
who could do that beauty
who could do the beauty around you
who could
have babies coming out of
a woman's body
god god has got to be in
there somewhere in everybody's mind
the worst of the worst i think unless
he's completely insane i'm not insane
so i believe in god
and i believe that
i did when it comes time
and i talked to him if i could get up
there somewhere
and we're going to have an argument
about
everything i did
that's what people will tell me
and i'm going to talk to him
about everything he did
there's so many kids that die
in so many ugly [ __ ] ways bro
you could have stopped me anytime you
wanted you could stop that anytime you
wanted
it's got to be a purpose there's got to
be reasons
why things happen
i don't one thing i'm not is a fake or a
phony or a liar
i did a lot of horrible things but i'm
none of those things and i think that
god will look at me and say you were
none of those
i make lambs
and i make
lions
you're a [ __ ] lion
maybe that's the answer i don't know i
really don't know
it's not to really discuss now or tell
other people that their religion is
wrong or my religion is right or yours
is wrong or just you you this you're
muslim
he's alright
god will determine it at some time or
we'll go back to wicca
where all energy
our body is energy
when we die
our body energy goes and floats all over
to animals to trees to bushes that have
some another human
to other things
so
that's an interesting thought too so i
don't knock anybody's religion or
anybody's anything they have their own
opinions their own choice
that's what we need and we need to
respect everybody else's choices
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you